[Música]
hablamos también por supuesto de
economía en directo américa de france24
me acompaña en el estudio de luis méndez
zúrich louis qué bueno tenerlo aquí muy
buen día vamos a iniciar hablando de
nuestra región el sur del continente
americano porque en argentina se lanzó
un plan para controlar la alta inflación
lo hablamos ayer también louis así es
ayer se hablaba de una reunión que
tendrían las autoridades con los
empresarios pero ya hoy hablamos de las
medidas que han tomado después de esa
reunión porque hay que adelantar que el
indicador presentó una variación al alza
de manera mensual de 4.7 por ciento en
el mes de febrero al tiempo que a nivel
interanual alcanzó el 52.3 por ciento
esto según datos oficiales los anuncios
realizados por el ministro de desarrollo
productivo matías kulfas fueron dados a
conocer tres días después que el
presidente alberto fernández declarase
la guerra contra la inflación el rublo o
el rubro de los alimentos ha sido el de
mayor alza presentado en los últimos
días por lo que el ministro instó a las
empresas del sector a justificar los
incrementos al tiempo que pidió
retrotraer los a los que estaban el 8 y
el 9 de marzo del presente año en la
mayoría de los productos y también
anunció precios de referencia para tres
productos como el pan los fideos y la
harina pero el ministro calificó estos
incrementos como inesperados y
totalmente fuera de proporción no
descartan tomar medidas más estrictas en
caso de ser necesario escuchemos
nosotros trabajamos en una mesa de
diálogo y creemos que el diálogo generar
resultados no tenemos ninguna duda de
eso este por supuesto que en más de una
ocasión nos ha tocado tener que aplicar
la ley de abastecimiento y lo volveremos
a hacer si fuera necesario le aplicamos
en pandemia en marzo 2020 cuando
aplicamos un esquema de precios máximos
esperemos no tener que volver a ese
esquema tan rígido pero si fuera
necesario lo haremos
pero otro país que también avanza en
contra la inflación es brasil donde el
gobierno anunció la eliminación del
impuesto al etanol y a 6 productos
alimenticios todo esto para contener los
altos precios en brasil de acuerdo con
el instituto nacional de geografía
estadística la variación porcentual en
el mes de febrero a nivel mensual
alcanzó un punto y 10.8 durante los
últimos 12 meses y pasamos ahora a
hablar de rusia donde a partir del
conflicto con ucrania louis las
clasificadoras han tomado medidas contra
ese país de que me estamos hablando en
este caso te hablo de una de las
calificadoras standard and poor's o
global rating que es una de las 13
principales a nivel mundial y anunció el
retiro de las calificaciones sobre rusia
y sus empresas antes del 15 de abril en
el comunicado standard and poor's
recuerda que fue el 15 de marzo cuando
la unión europea anunció la prohibición
de suministrar calificaciones en rúsia y
previamente el 9 de marzo estándar
global rating había suspendido todas sus
operaciones en ese país por el momento
el gobierno ruso no sea sobre esta nueva
medida pero en general la clasificación
crediticia de rusia ha empeorado durante
las últimas semanas en parte por la
expectativa que rige sobre el pago de
compromisos que ya están en periodo de
gracia la calificación de riesgo
constituye un elemento fundamental para
el desarrollo del país o las empresas ya
que gracias a la opinión de estas
empresas las compañías pueden llevar a
cabo la colocación de títulos para
obtener más recursos a largo plazo
frente a lo que ofrecen el sector
bancario tradicional vamos a áfrica
vamos a egipto porque la moneda de ese
país ha estado devaluándose durante los
últimos días porque esto o louis se
presenta luego de un periodo de dos años
de estabilidad monetaria y luego de que
el banco central de esa nación anunciara
tras una reunión de emergencia un
incremento en la tasa de interés de
referencia esto de un punto porcentual
que la llevó de 9.25 a 1 10.25
debido en parte a una inflación que
alcanzó 10 puntos porcentuales en a
nivel anual en el mes de febrero todo
esto por los altos precios de los
alimentos que tuvieron un alza de 20.1
por ciento de esto con cifras oficiales
también está impactando el alza de los
precios del trigo que procede en su
mayoría de ucrania y de rusia y vamos
ahora a hablar de los indicadores
económicos cómo está los mercados a
pesar de toda esta tensión que existe
entre rusia y ucrania los elevados
precios de los energéticos y también la
presión inflacionaria en los mercados se
están comportando con buenos números
sobre todo en asia donde ya cerraron de
manera positiva a lo largo del día en
tres de los principales indicadores por
otro lado también vemos en europa que
las operaciones se están desarrollando
con números positivos a lo largo de la
mañana que nos trae como cifra el día
louis mira que ver en este caso con los
214 mil millones de euros que estaría
revirtiendo el gobierno chino como parte
del cobro del iva todo esto para
impulsar el crecimiento económico louis
gracias entonces por toda la información
nos vemos más adelante con más economía
pasamos a ver nuestro reportaje